hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
as everyone knows from the perspective
of humans time only moves in one
direction and it's incredibly hard to
predict the future but over the years
there's been a select few who have
managed to do this and some managed to
predict up to a hundred years in the
future with chilling accuracy I wanted
to do something fun for today's episode
so today we'll take a look at some of
these fascinating cases our first
visionary needs no introduction
it's Nikola Tesla a Serbian American
inventor electrical engineer mechanical
engineer and futurist was instrumental
in the development of AC power motors
wireless communication and too much to
mention without bogging down this video
he stated the following as early as 1898
I proposed to representatives of a large
manufacturing concern the construction
and public exhibition of an automobile
carriage which left to itself would
perform a great variety of operations
involving something akin to judgment
this description does sound something
like a self-driving car when they're
navigating a road they do have to make
split-second decisions and how to
proceed which very well could be likened
to a form of judgement in 1926 Tesla
also described wireless devices that
would incorporate video and telephone
technology and work over a network very
much like the Internet quote when
Wireless is perfectly applied to the
whole earth we shall be able to
communicate with one another instantly
irrespective of distance not only this
but through television and telephony we
shall see and hear one another as
perfectly as though we were face to face
despite distances of thousands of miles
and the instruments through which we
shall be able to do this will be
amazingly simple compared to our present
telephone a man will be able to carry
one in his vest pocket
in quote this sounds a lot like video
calling and smartphone communication of
course a hundred years ago a simple long
distance calling didn't even exist
Tesla once again proved to be far ahead
of his time but he wasn't the only one a
lesser-known man by the name of John
Watkins also made some startling
predictions in 1907 engineer John
Watkins wrote a piece titled
what may happen in the next hundred
years within the article Watkins made
lots of predictions for the next century
and some ended up being amazingly
accurate man will see around the world
persons and things of all kinds will be
brought within focus of cameras
connected electrically with screens at
opposite ends of the circuits thousands
of miles at a span this really could be
likened to the internet and video
sharing ready cooked meals will be
bought from an establishment similar to
our bakeries today in 1900 bakeries and
butchers were some of the most common
ways to get your food there's no such
thing as keeping it for a long time
freeze dried and packaged foods didn't
exist and neither did electric
refrigerators and one last one wireless
telephone and telegraph circuits will
span the world a husband in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean will be able to
converse with his wife sitting in her
bedroom in Chicago we will be able to
telephone to China quite as readily as
we can now talk from New York to
Brooklyn so surprisingly what concept'
the same thinking as Tesla here
unfortunately he would die in 1983
before he saw a single one of his
visions come to fruition unlike any of
the other people in this episode the
next visionary actually inspired true
inventions that affected all of our
lives American inventor and engineer
Vannevar Bush designed influential
analog computers during the 1920s and
30s in 1922 he was one of the founders
of the Raytheon Company
by the early 1940s he was the most
influential scientist in America
directing thousands of researchers and
military generals only answering to the
President himself he was even in charge
of the atomic bomb after the war he
wanted to turn all of the scientific
efforts from destruction to peace in
this he could force the academic
knowledge being lost as time went on
with 1940s technology there was simply
no way to collect organize and access at
all his solution was nothing short of
prophetic in a 1945 article entitled as
we may think published in the Atlantic
Monthly Bush proposed a device that he
called a mimics mimics being short for
memory extension this device could store
and connect information and thus work as
an artificial aid to memory he came to
the conclusion that current systems of
organizing information by alphabetical
order would be inadequate a new system
was needed a system that was more
flexible and should also work like the
human brain it would be a loose web of
information connected by links between
them quote wholly new forms of
encyclopedias will appear ready-made
with a mesh of associative trails
running through them ready to be dropped
into the Memex
and they're amplified Bush went on to
describe the ability to retrieve several
articles or pictures on a screen he
believed that people would create links
between related articles each user
saving it fathers to experience in other
words people would create what we'd call
websites today where you can click on
links and it takes you from one page to
another
the mimics machine itself is what we'd
call a desktop computer there was much
more in these writings but I'm weary of
this video's length so I'll leave you
with the sheer impact and the influence
of Bush's writings these writings
directly inspired some of the
co-creators of the internet in the 1960s
it also inspired the Maus the Xerox Alto
desktop computer in the 70s that
inspired Steve Jobs it also inspired the
graphical user interface and not to
mention hyperlinks the very backbone of
the web it truly had all the core ideas
of the modern Information Age all the
way back in 1945 if there was a
visionary to fame ratio bushes would be
sky high he was one of the most
influential people ever to have lived
but hardly anyone knows his name
of course apart from those who have read
my book new thinking shameless plug in
which his contributions and threads of
influence throughout history and all of
our lives was heavily focused on in the
art of predicting the future there were
also some companies that tried their
hand
fuoco was an early pioneer in
electronics and were known for their
radios in 1967 for their 75th
anniversary they produced a short film
speculating on life in the distant
future the film's title the year 1999 ad
fingertip shopping will be one of the
many homemakers conveniences this video
console will be channeled into the store
of her choice there a camera will scan a
display of wares which she will select
by push button
another part of this console is a
household monitor screen which maintains
a watch on critical areas in the house
swimming pool or yard what the wife
selects on her console will be paid for
by the husband at his counterpart
console all bills and transactions will
be carried out electronically oh how
about some golf at Pebble Beach Saturday
afternoon great anything to get out of
here all right hold on a minute I don't
know the coast looks little dow coolers
are low moving in let me check Mexico
City it's interesting to see the 1960s
conceptions of online shopping and
paying bills electronic funds and
transfers and even communication between
individuals anywhere in the world and
there's even some smart home elements in
there too
our next prediction has a strange twist
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic so if what I say now seems to
you to be very reasonable then I would
fail completely only if what I tell you
appears absolutely unbelievable having
any chance of visualizing the future as
it really will happen flamed science
fiction author arthur c clarke teamed up
with stanley kubrick to make the film
adaptation of the novel 2001 a space
odyssey in the 1968 film two astronauts
can be seen reading a newspaper on
something that looks a little something
like an ipad the description of the
device is especially amusing quote when
he had tired of official reports he
would plug his news pad into the ship's
information circuit and scanned the
latest reports from earth one by one he
would conjure up the world's major
electronic papers which she could read
with comfort when he finished he could
flash back to the complete page and
select a new subject for detailed
examination one could spend an entire
lifetime doing nothing but absorbing the
ever-changing flow of information from
the new satellites it kind of sounds
like someone reading Twitter on an iPad
now he is the twist this description was
so astonishingly accurate that Samsung
used it to legally defend its Galaxy
Tablet when Apple sued for patent
infringement
[Music]
Isaac Asimov was one of the world's most
prolific science fiction writers having
written or edited 500 books over his
four decade career the Russian born
writer was famous for books such as I
Robot naturally his work contained many
predictions about the future of science
and technology
after visiting the World's Fair in 1964
he predicted the rise of cars with robot
brains quote much effort will be put
into designing vehicles with robot
brains vehicles that can be set for
particular destinations and that will
then proceed there without any
interference by the slow reflexes of the
human driver more than 50 years later
companies like way mo Tesla and others
are testing self-driving cars some of
his other predictions from 1983 include
quote a mobile computerized object that
will penetrate the home and the
increasing complexity of society will
make it impossible to live without this
technology in quote I think that last
point is especially insightful many
people today think that society is
indeed too complex to get by without it
he goes on to predict that computers
will disrupt work habits and replace old
jobs with ones that are radically
different this happened heavily from the
1980s into the end of the 20th century
during a 1988 interview
Isaac envisions the education of the
future he stays that three computers
we'd have access to connected libraries
which would act as a teacher in the form
of access to the gathered knowledge of
the human species once we have outlets
computer outlets in every home each of
them hooked up to enormous libraries
where anyone can ask any question and be
given answers be given reference
material be something you're interested
in knowing from an early age however
silly it might seem to someone else with
your interesting and you ask and you can
find out and you can follow it up and
you can do it in your own home in your
at drone speed zero direction and your
own time then everyone will enjoy
learning still SMF was wrong or at least
slightly wrong on one thing though he
predicted that technology would
revolutionize education and this is
arguably correct but he did go on to say
that traditional schooling would become
outdated as kids would be able to learn
everything they needed to know from
computers at home that might be
technically possible but it also assumes
that kids will spend all of their time
using this technology to watch pointless
videos or play for night up next we have
a company that predicted their own
future in 1987 Apple made a promotional
video entitled to knowledge navigator
and look to the future
let's take a look their party next
Sunday today you have a faculty lunch of
12 o'clock you need to take Kathy to the
airport by 2:00
you have a lecture at 4:15 on
deforestation in the Amazon rainforest
right excuse me Jill Gilbert is calling
back great put her through
I'm Mike what's up aha is this one of
your typical last-minute panics for a
lecture material no no no that's not
until um 4:15 the tablet device that is
talking to you could be seen as an early
imagination of an iPad the interaction
itself with the talking head is like
Siri or Google assistant the command
show me my appointments would do mostly
the same thing show me my appointment
[Music]
you have 18 upcoming appointments here
in the first three all day Monday during
his work the professor takes a video
call from a colleague it appears in a
separate window on the device this could
be Skype in a nutshell okay so we have
one more predictor of the future before
we finish off Raymond curse world's life
and Korea is pretty amazing so you want
to see a full episode on him let me know
in the comment section below
in 1963 at age 15 he wrote his first
computer program it was pattern
recognition software to analyze the
works of classical composers and then
synthesized its own songs in a similar
style admirable even today but
absolutely unheard of in the 1960s his
inventions are numerous text reading
software speech recognition devices and
five of his novels have been bestsellers
just imagine if you were not here how I
know what it says and be lost but
because of the technology because of the
interfacing of speech synthesizers with
these instruments I can push the button
know what it's saying by listening to
it's a hit record button to start and
stop record sequencer activated record
low speed one he's currently the
director of engineering at Google in all
of this he's made dozens of predictions
over the decades with a pretty good
track record in the 80s
Kurzweil extrapolated improvements of
computer software performance to predict
that computers would beat a human chess
player by the year 2000 in 1997 chess
world champion Garry Kasparov
was defeated by IBM's deep blue computer
in a well-publicized chess match during
the late 80s he predicted that the
wireless internet will become practical
for mainstream use in the early 21st
century in one of his books in 1999 he
predicted ebooks face recognition
software and nanotechnology and these
are just a handful of examples an
evaluation in 2012
determined that curse walls predictions
have been correct and astonishing 86% of
the time interestingly in 2008 he told
an expert engineering panel that solar
power will scale up to produce all of
the earth energies needs in 20 years
according to him we only need to capture
one ten thousandth the energy from the
Sun that reaches the Earth's surface and
that apparently should supply all of our
needs
we'll be waiting for this one he did get
some things wrong there Ray Kurzweil
thought that the economy would continue
to boom from the 1998 dot-com frenzy all
the way through to 2009 he didn't see
the dot-com crash coming evidently he
also stated that by 2009 the majority of
text would be created using continuous
speech recognition this is clearly not
the case but hey an 86 percent success
rate isn't too bad so with that it
brings us to the end of the visionaries
who correctly saw the future it seems
that to some of the greatest minds there
were some common threads self-driving
cars and all-in-one pocketable
communication device and worldwide
instant communication it's almost like
these things are inevitable it's very
interesting to think about I'm sure a
few of you out there would be thinking
so what all of these predictions were
easy well in hindsight definitely but
not so fast
in 1899 Charles dill the Commissioner of
the United States Patent Office famously
said everything that can be invented has
been invented so it really takes some
insight to get this right so who was
your favorite predictor of the future
Nikola Tesla predicting smartphones John
Watkins predicting Modern Life Vannevar
Bush conceptualizing the web and most of
our modern life in 1945 the Philco
company predicting online shopping in
1967 2001 a Space Odyssey predicting
iPads in 1968 Isaac Asimov predicting
computerization and robotics or rakers
wells many predictions during his life
let me know in the comment section below
it's just amazing what the human mind
can envision when imagination is
combined with wisdom so thanks for
watching if you did enjoy this video and
want to see anything on science
technology business and history
feel free to subscribe to this channel
there's heaps of interesting episodes on
you so my name is to go go and you've
been watching cold fusion
now I'll catch you again soon for the
next video cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]